hey guys how's it going so today most of
you guys are probably well aware that
the new os update for your wonderful
iphone just was released and when you
update you get access to apple music
which is apple's new streaming service
pretty much comparable to spotify now i
updated this morning and i actually have
not got a chance to play with apple
music yet so this is gonna sort of be my
live
reaction my commentary exactly what you
see the only thing that i did do was
open it this morning and listen to beats
one and before we go any further i don't
have opinions on very many things in
life i mean i have them but i tend to
keep them to myself my only public
opinions
really that that you guys are aware of
is my stance on guns and beats music
beats by dre if you look at my air
conditioner just came on but i'm
sweating my freaking balls off so i'm
going to keep it on i don't have a ball
i have to turn it off because it's
really loud
thank you nest anyway when apple bought
beats by dre
a piece of me died because i absolutely
do not like the headphones they don't
really actually sound that great
compared to bows which i'm a huge fan of
this is not a beats bashing session as
upset as i was in the grand scheme of
things i mean it all kind of made sense
you know at the time i was a little
angry a little upset but essentially
what they were buying was the beats
service so that essentially became apple
music and it's kind of amazing because
this is something that's going to be
cross-platform it's not just going to be
on apple so that's pretty huge for apple
to be going outside of their apple
comfort zone which is usually uh not
something that they do anyway let's
let's open it up i don't even know what
i just said i'm not sure it doesn't
matter do you care don't care you're
still watching the video and if you're
not well
sorry so my question to you guys before
we get into this is i want to know in
the comments below what streaming
services do you guys use do you use
pandora do you pay for pandora to use
spotify do you pay for spotify i mean
there's been so much drama in the news
especially because apple was saying that
they weren't going to be paying any of
their artists in the first three months
that you guys have like a free trial
well if you've been freaking hiding
under a rock you're gonna know that
taylor swift got everyone in a little
tizzy and
basically made apple change their entire
music procedure i have a feeling it was
all a pr stunt anyway and it doesn't
really matter because that's pretty much
all entertainment and hollywood is it's
all planned and
calculated and coordinated and that's
just how it is but guess what are you
entertained i'm entertained so that's
all that matters all right let's take a
little peek at what we got here so since
i haven't done any of this yet
apparently this little for you section
it must
be asking me what i like well let me
tell you what i like tap once on the
genres you like or tap
twice on the ones you love um
i like dance what what's the difference
between dance and electronic i don't
know i'm not sure let's see i love
classic rock i love alternative am i
done yet can i stop now hold up wait a
minute let me put some booty in it they
just so you missed it the last album
that i pre-ordered was the vhs album by
x ambassadors who i i absolutely love
this album is so good real into it and
i'm playing around like freaking
mrs claus over here
back to what's important so i've been
real into this song
she told me to worry
about it she told me don't worry
no
more oh yeah
what what can you not where can't you go
you can't go without it in my face when
i'm with okay copyright i'm probably
gonna copy from strikes whatever okay
we've got our top songs now are these
top songs that it thinks that i'm gonna
like are these top songs on itunes
discovered on connect oh yeah what's
that what's this what's this discover on
connect
into it potentially into it apple music
editors what's this
i want to be an apple music editor how
do i become one interesting okay so
here's the radio
which i'm assuming is a lot like itunes
radio but i don't know if you guys
experienced the same thing that i
experienced the past
year and a half
my itunes radio did not work until
three weeks ago because i would dry
every freaking week classic metal give
me something good what's it gonna be
iron maiden
i want something a little more a little
more metal
ac dc
oh my god this song
brings back way too many memories of
which i do not want to discuss if you
read my book the part where i used to
work at the chiropractor's office
that was like their theme song i don't
want to talk about it but i do want to
talk about it electronic let's see we're
listening to the radio right now
she told me don't worry
no more okay follow up for you
okay so i missed this in the whole login
choose three or more of your favorite
artists
all right i'll do it let's see three or
more okay one republic zed love zed love
taylor swift thank you love calvin
harris bring it she's on me don't worry
about it oh ellie golding come here yum
yes sexy
imagine dragons yes you get two okay
you should know everything that i like
you should know absolutely everything
that i like because you can see how many
times i've listened to things all right
i think this is good enough more artists
you get my freaking you get my you get
my drive you get who i am find more
artists and curators see i gotta follow
people who the hell am i following oh
i'm apparently following all of the
things that i just
tapped and said i liked is that how this
works what the hell's going on am i am i
crazy austin mahone hey holla i follow
you i'll follow skrillex that's that's
apple music i don't think i did a very
good job of even showing you
anything because there really wasn't
much to see
how do you make a playlist
so you can start a station they i mean
this is it's the same as spotify it's
the same as like everything like pandora
start a station off of a single artist
or a song cool can't wait um you can
show it on itunes you can share the
album share the song add to playlist i
think it happens that i had a playlist
these are all my itunes playlists
um we're gonna need to delete those
clearly those are a little outdated
absolutely
sweating in this house right now i turn
my air back on and let me know what you
guys think of apple music you know i
think it's cool not really sure how i
feel
i don't really actually have any
feelings if i can listen to music and i
don't know i don't know i don't know how
i feel i'm conflicted i'm having i'm
having some some thoughts i'm just
willing to spotify you're gonna make me
switch you're gonna make me change
you're gonna give me this three month
trial you're gonna give me a little
taste of what i can have and then you're
gonna auto renew and make me pay for it
there is a way to actually shut off the
auto renewal you just go up here into
your little settings to do is uncheck
that little uh
little ticker
and you'll be set to go and it won't
auto renew in three months anyway that's
it let me know what you guys think of
apple music let me know
let me know all of your thoughts i have
not been able to fully process my
complete thoughts yet because i've only
been using it for four minutes
four to five minutes of apple music
uh yeah see you guys in the next video
the next one i believe will be a
little
review
comparison
discussion around the steel apple watch
so see you soon